und bei mir am Interview Set inzwischen
Bernd Baumann angekommen der erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der
afd-fraktion im Deutschen Bundestag da
war man die haben ja gerade der Rede von
kinopropalla gelauscht da viel mehr als
erstes auf dass er gesagt hat die
Impfpflicht abgewendet das hat das
Verdienst der AFD also wenn ich mich sie
waren ja im Bundestag selbst bei diesen
Debatten dabei wenn ich mich da richtig
erinnere waren das aber auch noch andere
Fraktion die FDP z.B im großen Teil ich
glaube auch was der Union haben sich
viele gegen die Impfpflicht gewendet
heften sie sich da ein Erfolg an die
Fahnen der eigentlich an den auch andere
sozusagen
mit verursacht haben
immer die Frage wer hat das als erster
sozusagen zum Gespräch gemacht wird das
als erster auf die Agenda geschrieben
und das waren wir die das eindeutig
gemacht haben wie bei allen anderen
wichtigen Politikbereiche Migration
Energie sind wir die einzige
Opposition wir sehen das so die CDU ist
das schon lange nicht mehr auch in dem
Fall nicht
vielleicht noch ein anderer Aspekt sagen
gegen die trickstreiber will die AFD
Vorgehen wen meinen sie dann damit äh
ist da tatsächlich der besten Gemeinde
wir sollten uns ja nicht unbedingt auf
die Seite des Westen schlagen sagt
kinoprophaler aber seit 1949 sind wir
Westen die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
war Teil des Westens Teil der NATO ich
war Bundeswehrsoldat auch Teil der NATO
jetzt ist aber die ost-westspaltung zu
Ende seit 1989 jetzt sind völlig neue
geopolitische geostrategische Grundlagen
geschaffen wir müssen uns neu
positionieren auch als Europa innerhalb
der Welt das braucht mehr Souveränität
Europas biopolitisch aber auch
Deutschlands innerhalb von Europa das
ist damit gemeint ja aber die
ost-west-spaltung haben wir ja wieder
ausgelöst durch Vladimir Putin ja das
ist ausgelöst durch Vladimir Putin das
den Krieg angeht aber die Diplomatie vor
den Krieg die diplomatische Krise da ist
der Westen da sind die USA mit dran
beteiligt und der Schlüssel für den
Frieden hängt großenteils auch in den
USA es geht nicht um ein Frieden jetzt
Ukraine Russland das wird so nicht geben
das muss eine internationale
Sicherheitsarchitektur geben die wir
schon mal hatten die weltweit sozusagen
klar macht die Räume absteckt und
gemeinsam Frieden und Stabilität wieder
schafft was jetzt gerade gesagt haben
weiß dass er mir Putin haben sie da
Information ich habe keine Information
aber die Russen haben Interessen
legitime Interessen wie andere auch
legitime Interessen haben natürlich ist
das ein angriffskriechen
völkerrechtswidriger das macht die Sache
jetzt schwieriger aber langfristig
können wir Frieden in Europa nur haben
mit Russland das ist seit Jahrhunderten
so ähm
Parteivorsitzenden andere Lehrer wir
sollten andere Länder so leben lassen
wie sie es wollen es Studium Respekt und
Frieden statt Einmischung und Krieg wenn
man sich das jetzt mal auf den auf den
Überfall der Russen auf die Ukraine
ansieht also die Russen lassen ein
anderes Land nicht zu leben wie es will
Respekt und Frieden davon kann keine
Rede sein sondern Einmischung Krieg und
Massenmord sind das die alternativen
Fakten die man immer bei der AFD
vermutet heute nicht wir haben gesagt
doch das ist ein völkerrechtswidriger
Angriffskrieg mit allem was das bedeutet
zutiefst zu verurteilen was er im Grunde
meint ist diese Werte geleitete
Außenpolitik von Frau bärburg was
überhaupt nicht funktioniert es gibt auf
der Welt ganz unterschiedliche
Kulturräume auch Kulturräume die nichts
mit unserer europäischen sehr wenig in
unsere europäischen Kultur
Menschenrechte und so weiter zu tun
haben auch die Chinesen haben eine
eigene Kultur die ist innerlich anders
aufgebaut die müssen wir akzeptieren das
ist damit gemeint wir müssen
interessengeleitete deutsche und
europäische Außenpolitik machen und
nicht die Welt belehren nach
europäischen Werten die die nicht haben
und die die wollen bedeutet diese
Interessen geleitete Politik
Deutschlands auch dass wir zum Beispiel
Menschenrechtsfragen ausschließen
sollten aus dieser Interessen geleiteten
Politik die sieht nicht ausgeschlossen
aber die stehen nicht im Vordergrund wir
haben nicht die Welt zu belehren die
Welt zu missionieren die folgt uns auch
nicht die Chinesen 1,4 Milliarden mit
einer eigenen 2500-jährigen Geschichte
die haben anderes System nicht
individuelle Menschenrechte und das
funktioniert auch ich finde unser System
besser das westliche dass europäische
des bürgerliche aber die Welt ist ein
Großteilen anders organisiert das müssen
wir akzeptieren die zu belehren und
unsere Außenpolitik darauf zuzuschreiben
dass wir die bekehren und belehren ist
Unsinn das ist ein Teil dessen was wir
kommunizieren aber im Kern müssen wir
unseren Interessen wahrnehmen geoprische
Interessen wir müssen Energieversorgung
sicherstellen Absatzmärkte und mit dem
müssen wir zusammenarbeiten selbst mit
arabischen sozusagen klaren beherrschten
Unternehmen wie Saudi Arabien oder so
müssen wir vernünftige Politik betreiben
wir können nicht die weltmissionieren
ist ein absolutes Missverständnis von
Außenpolitik was Frau baerbock und die
Links grüne Regierung machen aber dann
müssen wir die
Menschenrechtsverletzungen Saudi-Arabien
und China akzeptieren nicht akzeptieren
wir können ja versuchen darauf
hinzuwirken wir können da Frau dafür
werben aber wie können sie nicht zwingen
durch Sanktionen durch Belehrungen
aufdringlich werden das können wir nicht
das sind selbstständige Kulturen die in
sich ruhen Jahrtausende alt anders
organisiert sind die Welt ist nicht voll
von Europäern und europäischer Kultur
das ist ein ganz bestimmter Kreis das
hält uns auch zusammen im Westen
Menschenrechte Bürgerlichkeit Freiheit
Demokratie aber große Teile der Welt
sind anders organisiert und die wollen
auch anders organisiert bleiben es gibt
andere Möglichkeiten sich zu
organisieren da sehen sie in China
ungeheure Erfolg Wohlstand Milliarden
Menschen aus dem Elend geholt in kurzer
Zeit ohne unsere Version von
Bürgerlichkeit Menschenrechten
Demokratie das ist möglich wo die
wirtschaftlichen Bedingungen in China
haben sich ja verschlechte in den
letzten Monaten ja ich würde sie gerne
noch auf eine Sache Hinweise sie haben
ziemlich sicheren Job weil nicht geplant
ist dass der Bundestag abgeschafft
werden soll ist mir jedenfalls nicht
bekannt was sie aber planen ist ein
anderes Parlament abzuschaffen nämlich
das EU-Parlament jetzt gibt es hier
einen sechstägigen doch sehr aufwendigen
parteiag zur Wahl von Kandidaten für
dieses Europäische Parlament die nach
Brüssel fahren und dann alles dafür tun
dieses Parlament dann abzuschaffen also
shopkiller in eigener Sache zu sein so
ungefähr wie geht das zusammen nein die
EU muss grundsätzlich reformiert werden
wir haben uns das jetzt jahrzehntelang
angeguckt am Anfang war alles prima die
Wirtschaftsunion sozusagen
Sicherheitspolitik miteinander zu
betreiben freie Märkte alles völlig okay
aber jetzt hat sich ein Zentralismus in
Brüssel ausgebildet der so nicht geht
der so nicht funktioniert und auch das
EU-Parlament ist ja keine wirklich
demokratische Veranstaltung die
einzelnen Länder haben ja ganz
unterschiedlich Abgeordnete Deutschland
hat nicht entsprechend seiner
Bürgerschaft Abgeordnete
Europäischen Parlament da ist nicht
sondern die Deutschen sind
unterrepräsentiert wie die anderen
großen Länder auch das ist sozusagen in
Vehikel von Demokratie wie das
EU-Parlament im Moment organisiert ist
und so geht das nicht weiter gut das ist
jetzt ihre Analyse der europäischen
Parlamente es gibt ja es gibt in der Tat
ja auch den Versuch das noch zu ändern
da müssen aber alle mit an einem Strang
ziehen
im Moment ist Europa in weiten Teilen
auch nicht Europa die EU wir sind die
Europäer wir sind zutiefst Europäer hier
von der AFD aus nur die eu-moment
vorgeht und wieso Mensch strukturiert
ist ist für uns ein großes Problem weil
es auch keine Probleme löst Migration
Außengrenzen Energie ist ja ein Desaster
was wollen sie die zerschlagen sehr
schlagen sind alles so fürchterliche
Begriffe wir wollen das neugründen wir
wollen sozusagen eine neue Gründung das
Ding muss europäisch neu gedacht werden
die Solidarität die Loyalität die Tiefe
Verwandtschaft der europäischen Nation
muss Ausdruck finden in der gemeinsamen
Organisation in der gemeinsamen
Verbindung und da ist die jetzige Jugend
hier weg wir müssen das neugründen
zutiefst reformieren wenn die neuen
Abgeordneten der AFD in Brüssel eine
Menge zu tun haben 26 andere Länder noch
davon überzeugen
ich bedanke mich bei Bernd Baumann für
das Gespräch ja